[音楽]
まだ
終わっちゃいません今まで開けたのは所詮
は連番の360万円分麺絆っていうのは
当たれば1等と前後賞で10億円ばんて出
ますけれどもバラはほんと数字もバラバラ
なので全モーションはないけど7億とか
1.5億とか当たる確率はこっちの方が
あるような気がします知らんけどまだこの
数見てると本当に1週間ぐらいかかりそう
なので宝くじを機械に通すとあの当選し
てるかどうかわかる機会があるのでそこに
通すために今から全部開封していきたいと
思います
樽
待って開けるので順調悪いぞ
絶対無理やばいもう物量がマジで無理
ちょっと
Twitterで見て俺今回年末ジャンプ
を1袋買って見てたら1000万円で
うん
はいというわけで開け終わりました
すごいねこれバラだから1万円ずつ見
なきゃいけないからマジで終わんないと
思ったのでもうこれマシンで
間違いないと思いますそれで早速このバラ
を持って機械の方で通していきたいと思い
ます
場所移動
はいというわけで
宝くじ売り場横浜ダイヤモンドチャンス
センターの方にお邪魔しておりますでこれ
が例の当選してるかどうかを調べられる
マシーンでございます見たことないよ俺
こういうの調べるのね
通せばバーンって分かるということでしょ
そうだと思うとりあえずバラはまだ調べる
前に1回連番が本当に合ってるのかどうか
ひょっとしたらさその抜けてるかもしん
ないじゃん当たりが一番そこのチェック
からやっていきたいと思いますお願いし
ます
[音楽]
朝までやってたのでひょっとしたら抜け
てる可能性があるのでこれでこの
カウンターがもし0じゃなくなった瞬間
えー見落としがあったということになり
ますおそらく0円になると思います
[音楽]
えこれ見落としがったってことですよね
情けね
ダブルチェックでやってたのに
消えちゃいますか
[音楽]
すいませんちょっとバカかもしれないです
僕もう一枚あった
[音楽]
またありました感じですかね
急に行きました今3
枚ぐらい
[音楽]
ちょっと待ってくださいね
ちょっと
[音楽]
待ってくださいマジっすか1
枚を見逃していたやばい
声出ないやばい
[音楽]
2万円見落としていたということですか
これです
もう見
[音楽]
落とせ
待ってあれもう1枚だった感じか
ごま見逃してる無理だもう辛い
[音楽]
6万円見逃してました
スパチじゃないってやばいねやばいよこれ
大好きもいたじゃん3人がかりでしっかり
当たり外れ負けたつもりだったんですけど
もさすがに朝までやってたんでちょっと
意識がなかったんでしょうか6枚見逃して
ましたマジでアホすぎる自分がやばい
やばいよ
本当に来てよかったこんな感じだと
まだまだ出そうだよねこの
調子で
連番で10億
期待しております
[音楽]
はいというわけで今僕が家で自分たちで
サーベット俺と大地君で調べた連番の
ハズレを全部一応念のために調べてもらっ
たところなんと
11万5700円見逃しておりました
やばいいいじゃない
本当に笑えない
11万円見逃しとんよでもやっぱなんか
100万円分とかバケツがあって
メンバーだけど360万円分くらい見た
わけなんでやっぱ相当精神的にもきつかっ
た正直
数字が何かわかんなくなってきたとする
からこれまた1つ勉強になりましたね
ちょっと金額というか
宝くじ枚数多いとちゃんとお店で見て
もらったか絶対いいです絶対見逃す連番の
攻撃金額相当変動しそうなので引き続き見
ていきたいと思いますじゃ次は
当たりも一応確認してもらいましょう
これは当たりを見てるので確実に行きます
自分にハズレが入っていたらやばいです
[音楽]
すごいな全部当たりだとこんなに増えてく
のか
見ていきます
やばくないめっちゃ外してるんですよね
当たりしか入れてないと思ってたのに
めちゃくちゃハズレが入ってたんで
ちゃんと確実に3人でバッチリ確認する
バッチリ確認してもしっかりミスってるの
で今後一生自分たちで宝くじの当たり外れ
確認しませんちゃんとお店で見てもらった
方がいいのかもしれませんこれぐらい毎週
が多いと
本当にびっくりしたよね当たりだとは思っ
てたのが78枚外れだった
相当注意深く数えれる人でも見せる可能性
がある枚数でしたはいというわけで今まで
の当たりの数正確にお見せして調べて
もらったところ
123万7千円でした
[音楽]
まあ当初僕たち調べたところ113万円
ぐらいだったんですけど+10万円という
ことでちょっと得した気分ですあっては
ならないことですさあというわけで本番は
ここからですバラ見てない部分かなりあり
ます一応回転して持ってきたのでここで
全てが決まります
残り300万円分ぐらいかなバラ
早速調べてもらいたいと思いますこれは
マジでまだ見てないから
[音楽]
頼むぞまずは愛知の名駅前殺人センター見
てもらいたいと思います
俺はここで待つぞいやお願いします
[音楽]
マジでここからはまず何もわかんないよ
えっ
もう一番
すごいね同じ倍に見てるのに結構値段差
つくね
名前終わっちゃうよ
終わった
アイスが終わっちゃう
以上ですかね
愛知県の売り場の結果バラがこちらになり
ましたバナナ60万円分買って合計が
21万円でした
まぁまずはこんなもんねはいというわけで
ママあいつはこんなもんでしたまだまだ4
店舗残ってますどんどん行きましょう
次は大阪ですでは見ていきたいと思います
よろしくお願いしますなんか連番でした
ある程度さこの番号帯なんだみたいなやつ
があったじゃんなんか当たりそうなお店と
当たらなそうなお店がなんとなく見えたん
ですけどちょっとバラバラなの
[音楽]
終わった俺の夢が大阪終わりました
合計が18万円ですまあまあまだですあと
3店舗ありますまずわかりません俺は諦め
てません
次続いては俺が住んでいる街静岡です
タバコ店ですではよろしくお願いします
静岡ちょっと期待してるよ俺は
[音楽]
静岡静岡の合計が15万円でした今の
ところ愛知が21万円大阪が18万円
静岡が15万円で
静岡が今のところ一番低いだけどほんと俺
たちの運もあるから一概にお店がどうこう
入れるわけじゃないんですけれどもさあ
登るところ2店舗となりましたあとは富山
と
銀座最初はこれが生まれ育った町富山見て
いきたいと思います
後がないが
俺はまだ
諦めていないぜお願いします
[音楽]
終わりました
富山
合計金額18万円でした
まあまあまあまあまあまあ大阪と同じ
くらい当たってますねいや十分
ではないですけど
皆様お待たせいたしましたいよいよ最後に
なりました
少女のレッドを並び私が買ってまいりまし
た
西銀座
チャンスセンターここに全てをかけており
ます
10万円分ちょっと少ないんですけれども
それでも俺はここに
全てをかけて今のところ左側の方がなんか
高いのでこっちで最後見ていきたいと思い
ますではお願いします
お願いします
[音楽]
最後の挑戦が始まりました
この
身がどうなってもいい
戻ってくれ
[音楽]
あと300枚ぐらい釣ったとこでしょうか
まずのラストです
やばいやばい
なんでやばいマジでやばい
[音楽]
もうもう少しだやばい
終わりましたかね
なるほど
[音楽]
売り場の前
消えるかね金金
いつもの
ざわめき
なんてできないさ
明るく動画しめるはずだったのに
うまく
笑えずに
空を見ていた
俺のお金が散りになってくその
姿が
悲しい声で
溢れないように
最後に何か
君に伝えたくてそれなりに
戻せる
落ちを
僕は探してた
突然に
増えつつ現実いいとする
焦る僕
取り返しのつかない
金額
[音楽]
夢中で画面見つめて
心で思った
リツイート数がどうなったって10億
当てると
金が
外れになってしまった日から
何もかもが
違うく見えたんだ
300円もさんでも1万円も
君が
リツイートをくれたんだ
答えきれない
感謝をこの声に
乗せて
僕の
君の
街
へ届け
[音楽]
同点がくがこんなもんであっても
必ず
光輝さんが
きっと当ててくれる
[音楽]
はいというわけであれだけたくさんあった
宝くじ710万円分持ってしてもま
210万円
ぐらいかな
-500万円の損失になってしまいました
[音楽]
現実は厳しいですねはい
宝くじすごい量出てて
本当にたくさんの方も感じてるんで多分ね
710万円程度買ったところで夢はつかめ
ないですけどこの日本の中にはひょっとし
たら1万円分だけ買って10を当ててる人
とか3000円分買って1000万当て
てる人とかいるわけだからこれは夢あるな
というかこんだけ買っても当たんないこと
もあるし逆に少しでも勝ったら当たること
があるかもしれないそんな
夢のある世界それが宝くじだなとてしまい
ました
ねでもいずれにしようかわねて当たんない
からね
来年もリツイートよろしくお願いします
[音楽]